google cloud offers a wealth of managed
services and serverless options for your
workloads but many mission critical
services use compute infrastructure
directly and run on google compute
engine instances how can we improve
observability for those workloads
today i'm going to show you how to use
the cloud operations agent to do just
that welcome to engineering for
reliability with google cloud
first what are agents and why do we need
them
here is an example of an infrastructure
summary dashboard for a project with a
few gc evms in it
notice that we're not getting any data
about how our instances are using memory
that's because the vm hypervisor only
knows how much memory is allocated to
each vm not how much of the allocated
memory the vm is actually using this is
just one example of data that can only
be gathered by a process running in the
guest vm such as an agent
there are other benefits of running the
apps agent inside the vm
it monitors your vm instances without
the need for any additional
configuration after the install
it exposes many additional metrics
beyond memory and gives you better
visibility to cpu disk and network
performance and the apps agent unifies
gathering your metrics and logs into a
single agent
if you've been using google cloud for a
while you're probably familiar with the
legacy monitoring and logging agents
however at this point the app station
should be used in all cases
now that we've covered the benefits of
agents let's have a look at how to
install the ops agent
i'm going to show you how to install the
agent in three ways first we'll install
the agent on a single vm using local
commands
then i'll show you how to install it on
a fleet of vms by using agent policies
finally we'll automate agent
installation using terraform let's get
into it
from the project dashboard let's go to
monitoring dashboards
select the vm instances dashboard
here we can see that there's a vm
without any agents on it
let's ssh to that machine
once the ssh connection is established
run the commands to download and install
the ops agent
we'll link to the documentation that has
the up to date command in the episode
notes
after some time you'll see an
installation succeeded message for the
cloud ops agent
at this point we can go back to our
dashboard
and confirm that the vm is reporting as
having the latest version of the agent
installed
we can then go to the vm details screen
and see that we're getting agent metrics
for that vm including memory utilization
and details of cpu usage
so that's an easy way to install the
cloud apps agent on a single virtual
machine by using an ssh connection and
installing the agent through the command
line
that was easy enough now that the agent
is installed let's have a look at all
the additional data it's gathering from
our vm
let's go to our vm instances and select
rbm
the observability tab is a single place
to see monitoring and logging data
collected for this vm
in the metrics section we can see lots
of data like memory and disk utilization
this is just some of the information
that's being collected by our agent
running on the vm
the processes section shows what's
running on the vm and resource
utilization of all the various processes
again this information is only available
by having an agent on the vm
the memory section shows us how memory
is being used by the vm and finally the
logs section will show us all the logs
being collected from the vm
we can open these in logs explorer to
better understand where each of these is
coming from
so that's how all the additional data
being gathered by the agent is collected
in a single place and made easy for you
to use
the apps agent collects a lot of
valuable data but how can we install it
at scale across our vm fleet let's have
a look at automating the installation
and maintenance of the ops agent with
agent policies
let's start on the vm instances
dashboard
here we see that we have multiple vms
with no agent installed on them
we can install an agent on all of them
at once by using an agent policy
let's have a look at an example of how
to do that using gcloud we'll post a
link to the details of the command in
the episode notes but here's an example
that will require installing the ops
agent and all the instances in the
specified zone that match the operating
system and version filter
note that you will have to enable the
relevant apis in your project in order
for this to work again refer to the
documentation for those details
after some time the operation will
report a success
we can then go back to our dashboard and
see that the vms that match our
operating system filter and reside in
the zone we specified for the policy
have the latest version of the agent
installed on them
we can go to the details for one of the
vms and confirm that we're getting agent
information there
so that's how you can use agent policies
to ensure that the cloud apps agent is
installed and automatically upgraded
across a vm fleet
using agent policies to automate agent
installation and maintenance is much
more scalable and error proof than doing
it manually but even entering commands
like this is still prone to input and
human error let's have a look at how to
turn agent policy configuration into
code with terraform
let's start by defining our agent policy
using terraform
the agent rules section will define
which agent we want to install and
whether we want to enable auto upgrading
for it
the group labels os types and zones
filters will define which vms are
subject to the policy
to create the policy first issue the
terraform validate command to make sure
your code is correct
once it's validated use the terraform
apply command to create your agent
policy and confirm that the operation is
successful
once the apply command is finished run
the gcloud describe command to validate
that the policy has been successfully
created
finally verify that the policy has been
applied and that the agent has been
installed on the instances that are
subject to the policy
thanks for joining me today we covered
the ops agent how it differs from legacy
monitoring and logging agents manual and
automated agent installation and the
data that the agent provides to help you
improve the observability of your
services running on gce
i hope this helps you find issues in
your vms faster and keep your users
happy thanks so much for watching don't
forget to like and subscribe to never
miss out on more engineering for
reliability with google cloud see you
soon
you